wir hatten gerade schon von ralf schuler
gehört die zwei großen themen also der
winter knigge dass wir uns alle besser
an die maßnahmen halten und schulen sind
diesmal wieder ein ganz ganz zentrales
thema über das wahrscheinlich auch
gestritten wird warum
ja weil es viele bundesländer nach wie
vor nicht geschafft haben den
schulunterricht so zu organisieren
wie ist das rk ii in seiner empfehlung
vorsieht ab eine inzidenz zahl von 50
sollen die klassen soweit entzerrt
werden dass ein meter fünfzig abstand
herrscht guckt man sich um in der
republik dann ist davon weitestgehend
nichts zu sehen und da ist man im
bundeskanzleramt auch ziemlich sauer
darüber
man hat auf die schulen ja kein
zugriffsrecht bildung ist ländersache
und da haben die länder einigermaßen rum
geschlampt oder sachen einfach nicht
gemacht manchmal scheitert man doch
einfach an der lehrerschaft oder an
direktoren und da muss man jetzt gucken
wie man da weiter kommt also die kinder
müssen entzerrt werden die klassen
müssen erzählt wenn ein meter fünfzig
abstand das würde heißen mehrarbeit für
lehrer und unterricht in schichten und
wenn das an den schulen nicht
durchzusetzen ist dann werden wir an den
schulen auch weiter scheitern und dann
sind auch die schließung nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen
ja schließlich nicht ausgeschlossen sagt
jetzt zwar eine der prämissen des lok
downs vor zwei wochen der lockdown leid
weil eben schulen und kitas unbedingt
offen bleiben sollten
müssen eltern und kinder jetzt schon
befürchten dass es sogar heute schon der
zu der entscheidung mit
schulschließungen kommen könnte nein
also das wird heute auf keinen fall
kommen schulschließung werden nicht
geschlossen werden es wird ein
eindringliches dringen aus dem
bundeskanzleramt auf die
ministerpräsidenten geben und von
einigen ministerpräsidenten auch auf die
anderen ministerpräsidenten da ist die
lage jetzt nicht ganz so klar dass man
an den schulen etwas macht aber selbst
wenn man das an den schulen macht jeder
der an einer bushaltestelle in schulnähe
vorbeikommt sieht was nach der schule
vor der schule dort passiert da stehen
10 15 20 schüler zusammen die ich bei
dichter gibt es ein küsschen links und
ein küsschen rechts da wird sich gehetzt
und da gelten keine abstandsregeln maske
werden dann nicht getragen und solange
sich das nicht ändert so lange nicht das
bewusstsein da es sowohl bei den schulen
bei den lehrern und bei den eltern die
kinder müssen abstand halten und die
kinder sollten masken tragen dann sag
ich mal auf gut deutsch land fahren wir
zu weihnachten voll in die grütze weil
das was wir momentan woanders gut machen
mit geschlossenen kneipen mit nicht
stattfindenden veranstaltungen das
verliert deutschland gerade an den
schulen
peter sack uns noch ganz kurz wie es der
zeitplan für heute wann soll es dann
entscheidungen geben
ab 14 uhr ist dann die schaltkonferenz
11 uhr tag jetzt hinter mir im
bundeskanzleramt an das corona kabinett
also die krone relevanten minister die
kanzlerin wirtschaftsminister
finanzminister gesundheitsminister
bildung und alles ist dann mit dabei und
dann gibt es das dann gibt es die
videoseite und dann sagen wir mal und
wird im laufe des nachmittags wird es
dann eine entscheidung geben also da
jetzt nicht viel neues entschieden
werden muss außer dass man sich darauf
einigt dass wir im prinzip aus diesem
aus diesem lockdown light wird im
prinzip ein lock down mit ein bisschen -
also man kann sich jetzt ein paar sachen
freikaufen
wir können dann sagen wir treffen uns
mit den freunden treffen wir uns dann
aber nur mit diesem einen haushalt
dürfen wir uns da noch treffen unsere
kinder müssen sich jetzt einen freund
aussuchen mit oder freunden mit dem sie
sich noch verabreden dürfen also wir
kriegen kleine ausnahmen von der
eigentlichen harten lockdown keine reise
keine tagestour nicht mehr in bus und
bahn wenn es nicht zur arbeit oder zum
einkaufen geht also da gibt es jetzt
eine langsame verschärfung durch die
kalte küche und durch die hintertür
darauf müssen wir uns einstellen also
ich nehme an 16 17 17 30 dürfte eine
entscheidung da sein aber nele wir
kennen das das kann auch einfach wieder
länger dauern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren